صغير جغرافيا يحظى باهتمام الكبير في
واشنطن حيث تتباين المواقف حول طبيعه
السياسه الامريكيه التي يتطلبها الوضع فيه
وبينما تنتقد الاداره نفسها سياسات الرئيس
قيس سعيد وتدعوه الى العوده الى المسار
الديمقراطي كما تقول الا انها ترى كذلك ان
مصالحها مع تونس تستدعي التعامل بحذر مع
الخطوات التي يقدم عليها الرئيس الت
ونسي تعريف بالقضيه التونسيه نحن اولا انا
كان بشعب شرعي
قام النظام الحالي بالانقلاب على هاته
الشرعيه وضع تونس يعني في وضعيه
وضعيه هي مصيبه على الشعب التونسي مصيبه
على تونس التعريف يكون اولا الحديث حول
اخفاقات ربما التي حدثت في الوضعيه
الديمقراطيه التي كانت فيها تونس ولكن
كذلك
بالحديث حول ما يحدث الان في تونس ندعو كم
مسؤولين سياسيين الى اعتبار الشعب التونسي
رهينه وجب مواصله دعمه سواء اقتصاديا سواء
من ناحيه الاستثمار الشعب التونسي في حاجه
الى الوقوف معه معه في هذه المحنه
الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه في مقابل ان
النظام الذي يحكم الشعب التونسي اليوم
يخاطر
بمصالح هذا الشعب التونسي الاقتصاديه
والاجتماعيه نحن لا نتعامل مع جهه اجنبيه
بالمعنى الذي يذكره الرئيس للاسف الذي
انقلب على الدستور والذي حنف بالقسم الذي
قام به للاسف
الصوره التي تقدم اليوم عن الدوله
التونسيه صوره لا تخدم مصالح الشعب
التونسي الذي يعاني حقيقه من مشاكل
اجتماعيه واقتصاديه حاده وللاسف الوضع
الاقتصادي والاجتماعي في هذه الازمه يكاد
يصل الى حاله انهيار اي الصوتين تعتقد انت
انه يسمع اكثر في واشنطن الذي يجب ان يسمع
صوته صوت الشعب التونسي العالم يحتاج ان
يستمع للشعب التونسي وان يستجيب لتطلعاته
مواقف الادارات العالميه ايذاء ما يسمى
بالديمقراطيه كانت يعني مسانده نوعا ما في
اتجاه مسانده الشعب التونسي على الكل صفقه
الثوره التونسيه اليوم الموقف من هذا
النظام الذي
قام بانقلاب على برلمان منتخب
وقبول بانتخاب الامان باهداء 11% هذا نحن
نلومه على كل من وافق على على هذا نحن
نطالب كل الاصدقاء تونس بمواصله دعم الشعب
التونسي ومواصله الاستثمار في تونس مهما
مهما كان من يحكم في تونس
المنظومه الديمقراطيه الغربيه تعاملت مع
هذا الانقلاب واعتبرته امرا واقعا وتعاملت
مع مخرجاته ونقدر ان
عدم التناسق بين القيم الديمقراطيه وقيام
احترام حقوق الانسان واحترام القانون بين
هذه القيم وبين التعامل مع منقلب في
النهايه هذا فيه خلل حقيقه هناك خلل ويجب
ان يوجهه والديمقراطيين في العالم اكان
البيروقراطيه في هذه الدول او نخبه سياسيه
في
مثلا يجب ان يكون هناك تناسق والا فهناك
خلل اعتقد انه هناك حوار بين الكونجرس
والاداره فيما هو
المطلوب لانقاذ تونس هناك رغبه السياسه
الامريكيه فيما يخص تونس يقودها هدفين
رئيسيين الهدف الاول هو عوده الديمقراطيه
واعتقد ان هذا هناك ان هناك اتفاق داخل
الكونغرس ومع الاداره في ضروره عوده
الديمقراطيه في تونس لانه كان هناك اعجاب
بالتجربه الديمقراطيه في تونس خلال 10
سنوات الماضيه رغم بعض الاخفاقات او
معناها النقاط الضعف في هذا التحول الهدف
الثاني بالنسبه لامريكا هو الحفاظ على
تونس ان لا تنهار الدوله التونسيه ان لا
تصبح الدوله التونسيه دوله فاشله هناك خوف
حقيقي على تونس لانه قيس سعيد يقود البلاد
نحو الفشل
[موسيقى]
انا لا انصح هذا البرلمان لانني لا اعترف
بوجوده اصلا نحن هم النواب الشرعيون تم
الانقلاب علينا وتم الانقلاب على الدستور
وتغييره
بسيفه يعني تعسفيه
العديد من المتغيرات التي شابت الموقف
الامريكي من الرئيس قيس سعيد في البدايه
كانت تمت خشيه من الجانب الامريكي من
فقدان الحلفاء
المخلصين الذين كانوا يصنعون القرار
السياسي في تونس وكان ثمه اعتقاد فعلا ان
حركه الرئيس قيس سعيد ليست الا حركه فاشله
سوف تنتهي في غضون يعني حي الزمن قصير
ومع ثبات ان الرئيس قياس يقف على ارض صلبه
وانه وفي تماما
لخارطه الطريق التي اعلن عليها في 25 من
جويليه تغير الموقف الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
واصبح يشوبه لا اقول بعض اللين ولكن اصبح
يشوبه تقدير للطرف الاخر الذي يختلف عن
سابقي اعتقد ان اداره بايدن كانت حذره
اكثر مما ينبغي فيما يتعلق بانتقاداتها
لا التصرفات الاوليه قامت بها الرئيس سعيد
انه من المهم الاصغاء الى ما تقوله
الاداره
والسبب قول ذلك انها تشير للشعب التونسي
وتبين له ما بان الولايات المتحده تدعم
طموحاتهم نحو الديمقراطيه ولكن في الوقت
ذاته اعمال والاجراءات ايضا مهمه وهي
تاثير انا اعتقد انه الاداره الامريكيه
تقدر انه سياسه قيس سعيد هي التي تقود
تونس نحو الفوضى الحقيقي الجاسم الان في
تونس هو ما يقوم به قيس سعيد لانه اظهر
فشل كبير في تسيير سياسه الدوله انه يرفض
الحوار يرفض التشاور مع اي طرف سواء اطراف
خارجيه التي ت
فانه لو سالتهم بشكل خاص فان مسؤوليه
الاداره يقولون ان قيس سعيد
وهو بحركته الاستبداديه ادت الى قدر اكبر
من الاضرار بالاستقرار البلاد وليس
استقرارها من اين ترسم الخطا والصواب في
مقاربه اداره اداره او الادارات الامريكيه
تحاول دائما ان تجد يعني حل وسط مع الاسف
انا اتقدم في العديد من الامور الحلول
الوسطى لا تحل المشاكل هي تزيد في تعقيد
هذه المشاكل